legendary gymnastics coach valorie
Kondos Field built UCLA into a
collegiate powerhouse before retiring
last year over 29 years as head coach
condos condos field led UCLA to seven
NCAA championships and 22 Regional
Championships and she was named national
coach of the year four times we're
highlighting condos fields leadership
style as part of our partnership with
Ted our in our series ideas that matter
condos field shares how her athletes are
champions in and out of the gym in her
TED talk why winning doesn't always
equal success I realized that I needed
to fortify our student-athletes as whole
human beings not just athletes who won
so success for me shifted from only
focusing on winning to developing my
coaching philosophy which is developing
champions in life through sport miss
Valles she's affectionately known by her
gymnast joins us now good morning good
morning miss Val morning I like that
nickname from ya I absolutely love this
speech terrific and so important because
as you point out so many people do well
in life they have success but they're
damaged along the way so what's the
different approach to make sure that
that success is still possible but you
don't leave all that wreckage behind
absolutely I absolutely believe and
hopefully have proven at least in the
later years of my coaching career you
don't have to be a bully to win you
don't have to demean people to win you
can build them up and it's not about
being a powder puff you know this this
term tough love let's define what that
toughest and the tough is accountability
the tough is being able to be as I say
my TED talk respectfully honest I like
that phrase listen I uh contou needs
emotion your TED talk 15 seconds and 49
15 minutes and 49 seconds was fantastic
but I love that you you seem to have to
have a come-to-jesus me mean II mean
meeting with your own teammates because
but you were kind of a bully wouldn't
you say I didn't know what else to do I
got what was your style what was your
style
singing I grew up in the world of ballet
and I knew nothing about gymnastics and
what would you say to the judge I would
I literally would go okay Showtime
I can act I grew up onstage here we go
okay go harder go home and winners make
adjustments losers make excuses I
learned that one so what is so what did
what did your team say to you they can't
fronted you oh yeah they asked for team
meeting which I loved
yeah great I got yeah for two hours they
would say misspell remember the other
day when you said this to me when you
were making fun of my hairstyle where
you were asking me to go I would say I
mean I'm so ashamed of this I would just
say you know why don't you go looking
like a 3d mirror in the mic and that not
3d but yeah yeah in the funhouse yeah or
in that in a dressing room yeah instead
of just saying you gotta get in shape or
lose weight and it was in my head I
thought I was funny no and as they said
you know what miss Val if we all showed
up everyday in a great place without the
stresses of life yeah it would be one
thing yeah but you never know what
someone else is going they said they
wanted to be coached up and not torn
down which I thought was really
interesting so how did you feel valve -
they said that to you how'd you feel
mortified yeah I was embarrassed what
did you do you're hired to win your
expectation is you've got to win for the
other way I didn't know how to win well
how else am I supposed to win wouldn't
thank God it happened upon coach
Wooden's definition of success and he is
hailed as the greatest coach that ever
lived
and his definition of success is simply
successes peace of mind and knowing
you've done your best he never mentions
winning he never mentions winning he
doesn't mention winning in his books in
his definition of success you ask any
athlete he ever coached he never
mentioned winning well we all fell in
love with Kaitlyn how do you say Orlando
ha ha ha she because she seemed to have
such joy in her routines you were her
coach what role did you play in her life
because she taught look she taught you a
lesson - what was what was my lesson I
mean she's got me many well sure but
when she said listen everything you talk
yeah that's what I mean right
now she she was raised in a very
Elite high-pressured bullish environment
she's her face everything that tell me
to do I do the opposite she did her
freshman year she was a little rebel and
she she literally said hey I don't want
to be great again I don't want to be
great again and then she just looked me
and it wasn't she wasn't being snarky it
was kind of like she was giving me some
inside information miss Val I want you
to know everything you tell me to do I
do the exact opposite and I was like
well I'm not gonna be able to dictate to
her to change
I can't dictate to earn her trust I
can't say you have to trust me
no I have to take from you go what do
what what can parents take it's time
that we really look at the statistics of
our use and there are more reports of
depression and anxiety stress and sadly
suicide than ever before and if your mom
and dad sitting in the car don't say did
you win today
right right focus on the process and the
experience and enjoy your child is a
unique whole human being not a version
of a mini mini version of you and also
not someone for your bragging rights
yeah for your ego yeah yeah people
should look at your TED talk thank you
it's worth it's worth rific it's really
one of those thank you thank you thank
you very much